what's going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to do an epic
two-parter reaction here because on the
streaming service we're watching on it
they've combined part one and part two
here for season four I'm assuming it's
episode 11 and 12 combined because
sometimes with the streaming services
you just don't know it could just be one
long episode or they've just combined
both of them but anyway it's called The
Fugitive or just fugitive of Brooklyn
Nine-Nine John how are you I am excited
I like the Harrison Ford movie so I hope
this draws heavily from that how are you
hilarious ladies and gentlemen leave a
like they'd be very much appreciated as
always full length Reaction watch along
as we sync it with your own copy for
benign are available over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a
whole bunch of stuff exclusively over
there as well alrighty ladies and
Gentlemen let's see what this epicness
is all about
[Music]
[Music]
I haven't heard this song in a while
[Music]
we have an opening there's a full on
action scene
[Music]
and I forgot my Pico oh that dude's
hilarious
we just haven't decided whose apartment
we're going to live in I think Jake
should move in definitely Amy's prison
van overturned on Nevin Street it was
carrying nine convicts who are now at
large this is a Manhunt damn
residence Warehouse Farmhouse hen house
outhouse and dog house in the area your
fugitive's name is Dr Richard Kim yes
yes none of them are named Kimball I
didn't kill my wife you're supposed to
go I don't care I don't care Let The
Manhunt begin
whoever catches the most fugitives gets
to keep their apartment loser moves in
with the winner all right I'm in oh wow
if you like sleeping in a bed with a
thousand and pillows well I hope you
like sharing my one great towel
didn't buy it it was in the apartment
when I moved in Gross I am completely on
board you need your own space I had a
painting studio in my apartment was this
in the 90s did you wear overalls and no
shirt every chance I got yeah yeah and
then the kids came along you don't have
to paint now
[Music]
Terry loves acrylics Jake moving in with
you is my dream come true your apartment
is two blocks away from mine Jake will
be able to pop by anytime
imagine it he's had a tough day he's
fighting with Amy you know how he let
things escalate
there are only two witnesses who are
close enough to the crash to see
something one's on his way here already
his name is Marshawn Lynch Marshawn
Lynch Marshawn Lynch the football player
I don't know his Hobbies he's a funny
football player how come they never make
quesadillas with sausage you throw some
tomato sauce in there and call it a
pizza dealer what you think what is
going
Escape convict number one you can put
your bourbon holding with the other
three convicts wait other three yeah
Santiago and Boyle brought them in
that's right it's three to one oh [ __ ]
needing this anymore since you'll be
moving in with me a towel yeah your
towel
oh because it never fully dries
thermal imaging baby thermal imaging
baby I got this flow check performance
polo with moisture wicking technology
take a look at this map of the world you
just keep one of those on you of course
in case I ever need to prove my point in
an argument fine
[Laughter]
really I'm gonna do that
where did you grow up where were you
born what do you mind in there sir a
child tying his tie
oh man come on where did you guys even
come from your nightmares hey Amy allow
me to introduce you to Big Bertha
security we went to Homeland Security
yeah this beauty comes fully equipped
with thermal imaging a satellite link up
this is ridiculous and she's also got a
holding cell which is big enough for
three perks Jake counting this guy how
many perps have been caught in place in
the three purp set well Sarge we placed
three perps in the three perp cell so
the three purp sales full of three
purposes
oh drone a little help oh my God
I had a friend of work for that drone
company when they started out
draw better we have no idea what this is
I think it's a cookie
it's not pizza it's a cookie pizza
another case another case salt it's like
Google translator this is good we're
gonna crack this
diazia nope
she just need to take a dump yo you know
it was a dump we can use Big Bertha to
tap into the security cameras
oh
wow that is cool Homeland Security I'm
going up on my own yes sentience it's
Westworld oh wait a minute search I
don't have eyes on that room
hang on I'll find it
no God is so fast what do you want you
let me walk out of this building and get
into a car if anyone tries to stop
the score is tied left whoever finds him
wins yeah I guess you could say he's the
golden snitch wait was that a Harry
Potter reference God damn it really was
I started reading them because you love
them so much remember when I called in
sick the other day I was at home reading
order of the Phoenix
crazy oh I'm gonna catch this last
fugitive win the bet and then we're
going to live together for the rest of
our relationship just you and me and
towel makes three cool cool cool cool
cool cool just so you know at the end of
the six books
oh no don't dude you dare that was
almost a real spoiler when the choir
shouts the loudest the most powerful one
is silent that doesn't even make any
sense well I might have paraphrased it
incorrectly
Rob do you want to share your experience
with the group gladly okay so you know
how there's a Subterranean race of
lizard people living beneath the city
who control our minds with their
pheromones yes yes
of course escaped murderer where would I
hide Pizza Hut where oh I have no idea I
just thought if I gasped I could force
an epiphany and I did now that didn't
work either or did it still no unless
stop it
I just told him I saw one of them slip
back into his lizard home under the
streets that's where they make their
soup oh my God he's onto something
Captain don't try to be nice by giving
it crazy it's a manhole cover he said
that the lizard people live under the
streets he means the sewers he saw
someone go from the van into the sewers
look
it's a manhole cover
go down into a manhole and Escape into
the sewer near The Crab side copy that
we're on it
yeah we're also on it Jeselnik this
friendly competition thing is really
making them yeah top of their game right
now back
[Applause]
forward
back
forward use that Universal back line
forward and we're gonna go yes
foreign
[Laughter]
shut up I hear something please don't
shoot each other
NYPD free to keep your hand so we can
see them
[Music]
you have the right to an attorney if you
cannot afford an attorney what will be
appointed for you why did you stop
I'm done you win what
I love you I want to move into your
apartment oh I love you too oh my God
what a beautiful moment and you guys
Amy's ovulating as we speak wow
oh that's sweet when we were back there
racing through the Miranda Rights I just
looked over at you and thought
you're awesome and you're good at doing
things I mean sure I'll miss towel but
your happiness is worth way more than
winning some stupid bat oh you deserve
the towel
your apartment is better than mine in
every way imaginable you want to know my
first thought was when we dropped into
the sewer smells like home no he's lying
Ninja Turtles come on Terry we were in a
sewer he's guns to think about the
turtles yeah I'm gunsta Terry quit being
such a Malfoy yeah Terry he's a gunster
he's your van drive he had pictures of
my family he said he'd kill him if I
didn't help so I crashed the van and
jeselnick took my clothes but then
where's the guy we thought was the van
driver he vanished whoa I was killed at
least five people he's been in the
system since he was 11. that's when he
sold four thousand dollars from his
foster family and burned their house
down
this is the Foster family yeah why did
you see who the brother is come on man I
need your help to take down your brother
[Laughter]
hey babe nice legs why are you boxes so
you would know I'm not wearing a wire
your buddy Scott said I had to ah that
makes sense Scott's a perv
you watch it from go home
hahaha
George is a murderer now and he just
escaped from prison we think he might be
trying to flee the country you want me
to help you catch him like when X-Men
teamed up with Magneto to stop
apocalypse yeah right we need a theme
song the Pontiac Bandit and Jay got cops
oh taking down Crooks in the streets
where they live flooding with girls who
will hop for the bass there's a talking
police dog that helps them solve crime
bring them in you told me to cut a deal
I thought you'd maybe drop charges on
one or two felonies but do you know how
many crimes we're forgiving six that's
not so bad hundred
if Judy doesn't lead us to his brother
he doesn't get immunity look cap I want
to see George behind bars as much as you
do I hate my brother you can relate to
that right sir remember how Furious you
got that time your sister ended an email
with THX
the game is on
game is a foot like this
never mind it's not possible sure
damn Rosa how did you do that I have a
dark pass
now you know my deepest shame cool
yep
[Laughter]
a text change and I'm not on any of them
there's a Hitchcock Terry Amy Rosen
chain there's even a Hitchcock Gina
Scully chain
wow Charles poyle
it's off the chain that is sad damn
excluded you because you're kind of an
over texter over texture so you don't
remember the time you sent 97 unanswered
texts in a five minute span my phone
vibrated itself off the desk I think it
was committing suicide
[Laughter]
well the only thing we have to go on is
the word of one of your criminal friends
criminals that's how you see us is it a
crime to steal bread to feed your family
or to sell some weed so you can buy
video games or steal video games because
you smoked all that weed
we'll go do something with the hell out
of it
he's not a cop he can't be wearing any
of this it's just a windbreaker it's not
like I gave him a badge and a gun he has
both of those things it's not loaded I
just want a [ __ ] and say a cool cop
catchphrase
New York's finest just got a whole lot
finer
treat her gently you know that's not a
nice car right say that again
that's what I thought
I'll be the vineyard
I actually felt pretty dramatic I was
like this wasn't funny
you all want me to join your stupid text
chains I am 100 in these last 24 hours
have just been hell
oh it's just my former lover hello
sister
[Laughter]
you're on the office exchange are you
serious this is amazing yeah well I was
totally against it but Amy felt bad
because you seemed so pathetic
it worked does he have a scar on her
left cheek maybe what's the shape of the
scar just a general slashing I'll head
towards her you go around back in case
she makes a break for it
[Music]
this is a root Scarface friend is a ruse
he wanted us out of there so he could
help his brother steal the egg shot
glasses of soup oh you're wondering how
I got the whole tray Charming right out
of her hey
foreign
because you can't parkour up a wall it's
everything I don't like how baggy
basketball shorts are I even shook my
business some skateboarders the other
day and that's something worse
[Music]
oh no Sherry needs for eating glasses
it's not that bad sorry yes it is I used
to be Batman oh no I'm his dad
his dumb wheat getting shot at the
operator
I mean I'll watch that origin story
somebody knocked out the ballet stole
all the cars every single one so George
was here looks like Doug Judy was right
after all huh captain
why aren't you say anything it's because
you're so embarrassed for being wrong
oh no gerdy
shut up
oh no how do we even know George did it
I mean nobody saw him but there was a
prolific car thief at the scene of the
crime you talking about me I'm a cop now
no you're not if I don't have a badge
and a gun
The Thin Blue Line just got thick as
hell
yes
I'd rather get hit by a bus then get one
more from you Charles fine I've been
kicked out of things before at Camp I
found a slam book that the Lunch Ladies
had written about me oh I need to be
included so badly I'll do whatever you
say I literally have zero pride and
that's what I like to hear Charles
I'll make the introductions wait we
can't just be Europeans what country are
we from what languages do you speak
French Spanish
some Portuguese obviously Greek enough
Flemish to get by what about you brought
um I can do a pretty good Italian accent
you think you could milk me
terrible dinero I don't know
I'm just making America okay
nice cars and I might have a buyer this
is Maxine Dubois International
millionaire goes you he doesn't speak
any English this is his lawyer Carl
mangerson hey I'm a lawyer
cobra
I mostly deal with scrap and crap you
know oh what'd you eating there Serge
Cream of Wheat it's easy to chew and it
keeps you regular it's a favorite dish
of the elderly
why don't I get your wheelchair and a
box of diapers that's how he escaped he
dressed up like an old lady
[Music]
oh
George is here he's out back let's go
right now
NYPD don't move that crap he's getting
away
oh no
oh all right we can run right through it
these suits are fire resistant these
suits are not fire resistant they're not
why are they so expensive
you had to have known better we're gonna
show you a text and then two potential
responses you need to tell us which is
more appropriate Amy writes leaving the
Virgin Festival Gina
[Laughter]
597 596. smiley face smiley face cat
smiley face thumbs up or
okay it's a trick question the text
requires no response dang
looking for us put your guns down turn
around slowly
what the hell Judy ah Judy so bro you
friends with this cop nah it's thirsty
ass [ __ ] just desperate for attention
first yes [ __ ] okay captain now I know
you're gonna step in and defend me well
you were begging me to compliment
earlier oh my gosh
if you're not friends you won't mind if
I waste them right of course he Minds I
mean sure we're enemies but in like a
playful way like Tom and Jerry oh my God
was Tom trying to eat cherry
life is alive no no those can't be my
last words hi karamba
the hell
oh nice
we got to put bullets in his brother's
gun
I knew you didn't betray me I said that
accusatorly but I'm very happy
it's on you they was always friends now
imma get my immunity the ghost of the
talking dog haunts the priest
and that was a bummer note to end on
hahaha
[Laughter]
I underestimated your honesty and
Peralta I underestimated your instincts
yeah I'm gonna need a lot more from you
than that fine you're a good cop even if
you are a thirsty ass [ __ ]
solve a pretty intense murder there's
crap all over me hey Captain got you a
little something something
dirty nope but she is the exact same
make model
and color oh my God you stole this I
can't be driving a stolen relax man I
bought it at a used car lot for like 600
this is not a nice vehicle
hello sexarella
sexarella would you mind taking a look
before he hit send Charles you've
trained for this moment okay we trust
you just send it come here good job
oh boy I'm gonna do it
oh no she's gonna hit what
oh
whoa
I don't think there's gonna be a bus
yeah and and so forcefully God
she just did
damn oh wow
Gina's dead and I think Doug Judy's
brother was from a Saw movie
I mean I heard
that
she
dozens or stay on the show
I think they'd kill her off no I just I
wouldn't think so either I don't know I
mean I see something like this and I'm
like
expecting like a full body cast plot
line rather than her actually dying and
being off the show but at the same time
uh I mean it would certainly be an
interesting Rabbit Hole to follow the
characters now imagine what it will do
to boil is this when they take like
their four month break
oh maybe oh maybe they did have like a
long break right yeah between December
and April or whatever that was yeah yeah
I guess so
um Dizzle yeah that was uh
it's a lasting impression
why are we well if that was for last
episode she held Boyle learn to text and
that is the lasting impact
every time Boyle uses a phone in the
show we'll think of Gina
um yeah I hope it's like a tragic story
for her where she's like
you know like in a casket and it's
suffering neurological brain damage and
then when she's in the hospital like at
the end of the season
she's like
you know Pearl to kill me pull the kill
my now and then he ends up having to
pull the plug on her walks away and
commit euthanasia
I think that I think I think after four
seasons you gotta start having just a
little more drama infused it's a really
spice it up and oh [ __ ] you know just
keep those emotional beats heavy a
little harder than the comedy will be
that much fun you can still have the con
like after he pulls the plug you know
you can do a gag where like the
electronic bed like does crazy thing
with her corpse you know it's funny
because she's dead so you're just
flopping around and all that stuff but
you know what good woman before that was
yeah was a really touching emotional
yeah always killing a woman's funny yeah
it's funny this is the funniest death
that's why I didn't really laugh during
Dahmer uh you know it's unfortunate
there was a lot of Comedy potential
humor is just not laughing
I don't get why people think this is so
funny this is not a funny joke
but what is funny is when you trust
yourself
that's funny oh this was this was epic
this was great I don't know how most of
you guys experience this part one Parts
you imagine if it was cut up it was you
know week to week uh but I I think
watching in one go is actually a really
strong choice I I loved it like the
first half is is funny it's like a good
funny episode
um but but the second half is hilarious
like the second half is true but once
they team up
um Doug Judy and Andy Samberg like I I
think Craig Robinson is a wonderful
talent and I I think this is my favorite
role that he does sure uh there's
there's because normally like Craig
Robinson is is more uh he's just a
little more deadpan more dried and I
think he brings that subtle delivery
that he does a real like natural a
humorous delivery that he has but
there's a little more Charisma in life
and a little a little a little more
goofball nature to his character that is
more childlike you want to hang out with
or he's also less of a roaster like Doug
Judy does roast but I feel like other
Craig Robinson rolls roast harder yeah
yeah no this guy has a lot more fun and
he seems to be more endearing and be
more bemused by people too and so I I do
I do like his character a lot and so
it's my personal favorite role of Craig
Robinson but no that that was like a the
last half was was so funny it was
hilarious and it's actually a brilliant
two-parter to set it up where it's a
it's a fun Manhunt episode for you gotta
capture all these criminals and then you
got the one remaining person left where
you make it a little bit more uh
personal and focused so you get this
wrap around or you get this two part
where one ends on they're gonna move in
together Jake and Amy that's was really
touching note and then to get the second
half uh who was I don't know I don't
think we've seen it where it's like
Peralta Holt and uh Doug Judy yeah
there's a great Trio who's who's so
funny and they're the reoccurring bits
too you of the theme song and and it
does have you questioning like oh it's
gonna have a is he a Trader is he a
Trader and then you can only figure out
like moments before it happens like what
the next turn is going to be but I like
that the ends on a turn of he actually
was on their side uh for for this for
this particular situation he was
actually helping them out so and it's
perfectly comedic that yeah it's like
you're immune all of your past
transgressions are wiped or have been
expunged and he's just gonna go right
back to Pizza yeah like it manages to
have that it has its cake and eats it
too by being this epic Doug Judy you
know each season has one so yeah this is
like the most epic one yet and then
you're like but damn if he turns over a
leaf and they're just friends like what
is this gonna do for the show and then
of course he's just gonna be like no I'm
just gonna go back to doing and it's
perfect because then yeah you know it'll
show up again later and it'll be you
know a treat as it always is but yeah
having the three of them together and
having that tension I think it was
really lovely you know it was a this
two-parter had
the right amount you said it during the
scene where uh Holt tells off Judy about
Gertie out front of the the venue and
like I think the previous part with Jake
and Amy did a really nice job of having
those moments just be sweet and
endearing and and not worrying it's like
effortless it's like it's not even
concerned with the comedy so much as
it's just like it slides you into this
character moment and here I thought they
did nicely to do that too or yeah with
Holt at his car at least you have these
couple of moments that are just genuine
and do kind of catch you and and I think
it's nice the first episode yeah you
have this you know Manhunt you have this
bet but you also have something loving
and endearing and here it's more
something serious more something that
stops you in your tracks in a different
way in an opposite way yeah and uh and
yeah it's like as a yin and a Yang I
thought this did nicely to exemplify
what some of the best Brooklyn 99
episodes do which is hilarious comedy
all obviously and all the character
stuff but knowing wisely where to place
an office authentic moment well yeah I
think the the moment where he is yelling
about the car is supposed to be funny
for some reason it just read his like
about insulting the name of the car yeah
but when it's when it happened I was
like this is actually like a dramatic
seem to be like laughing about that at
all oh well yeah it's like it's it's it
it's funny to me because it would have
been made the later bits so much funnier
yeah it's like I got the sense that I
wasn't necessarily supposed to be
laughing at that but at the same time it
is inherently funny what is happening
there yeah because they to treat that
moment so serious even even Doug Judy's
reaction to him was like damn man like
calm down like like he like he was about
to get
like he it was probably like a dramatic
scene where you're like geez it didn't
mean anything by it you know like sorry
dude it's okay yeah but so then so then
when it does get taken and all the Jabs
about the car actually being like cheap
and not really anything like that it
made it that much funnier yeah because
we knew how serious Holt took this car
uh well and it was the right amount it
was it was close enough to the ground
like it wasn't so absurd that it's like
I feel like we have all had a moment
like that where you're ribbing something
or you're riffing on somebody and and
then you realize that you've hit a nerve
and they are actually serious about
something you didn't think was that
serious and so like that moment rang
true to that you know whereas a lot of
the humor on on the show is absurd once
a month though a subscriber or a patron
who does not take kindly to something I
say
um sorry I get that but the other B
story lines too in the uh in the second
half are also funny like the story about
boiled texting is that I think that
would be a it's a relate I've never
particularly been in that situation
where like why don't I I generally don't
I'm in a couple group chats and I oh the
test I'm the least interactive
not the biggest participant of group
chats uh but I I don't so I don't I
don't itch to be a part of a group chat
but I I I I it did a great job of
setting it up that even if if I was in
that situation
I would feel like extremely left out yes
you know surely I'd be like I just want
to be in it
not that I want to be like an active
participant all the time but that would
be hurtful if they like kept it from me
yes you know yeah and I think they
that's what made it really sing and but
it's also really relatable we're like
God you know whenever this person texts
they just blow up my phone
and it's it's stopped it's insistent
yeah I hate it so it's like they crashed
or like bring two relatable things out
of that have nothing to do with police
work
um but but it is funny it's a it's a
it's a funny relatable thing I think a
lot of us deal with with group text
situations or dexters
um and the it was a throw one a Rosa
Rosa territory
yeah that was like the least funny one
but there were still some hilarious
jokes yeah like that I think the writing
and the editing was solid and yeah it
was really really really funny
um and I like the pair of Rosa and Terry
when they do put them together yeah and
I like the understanding of Terry always
being all that hard that's always what
made Terry uh such a sweetheart is the
fact that he has always been like an
older person at heart like he's got this
it's an old look and appearance of of
this like they're super physically fit
Action Hero yeah and he can play action
heroes one of The Expendables
he is that guy but you know he's such a
softy a teddy bear on the inside he's
old soul at heart so I think fleshing
that out yeah there's just some really
fun that joke about Batman's dad oh my
god
oh oh what was the line even the guided
an opera or something yeah what was the
build up of like talking about him like
pretty much just being a loser then
ending it's just dying at the office
yeah it was perfect it was a perfect
line yeah
does any of you don't really know that
Batman backstory whichever you know
where it's going yeah
it's just like insulting like dumbass
dad's losers
average guy and also he died
yeah I thought this was uh brilliantly
done and uh like a pretty good
production value for this I'm like they
threw down yeah like they needed this
one to be special and then with a
cliffhanger like that
yeah one I mean I guess if they were
gonna take a long break I guess that's
what you do you're like oh damn and on
an event two-parter even though this
aired in two parts you know and then and
on a big cliffhanger
love how bus hits are are the most easy
to generally the most easy to see come
well I didn't see a bus hit coming it
was like really obvious it was about to
get hit by a car
but I didn't see a bus hitting her yeah
and 99 of the time I could see a bus hit
coming but I guess a bus hit has bigger
implications so I didn't see a busted
coming in this I thought she was gonna
get like hit by a car and it was gonna
be like you know
falls on top of it or just flies over
and like and it should be injured but a
bus hit with especially the way that
played was like ooh that's serious
um well yeah yeah I mean you're like
she's either got to be broken every bone
in her body or is being dragged
underneath right now because there was
not much low clearance I would love if
the next episode is she's just uh
working she's just bad
it's barely barely in barely an injury
yeah like you look at it up and about
since recovering from the hospital yeah
yeah you know I could survive anything
I'm Gina linetti ah yeah this was a this
was a very big Delight Afternoon Delight
sky rockets everything excelled ladies
and gentlemen what did you think about
this uh two-parter leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe hi
hey
this one is the most active one of them
all the fastest one the one is always
awake and wanting to play constantly
he just wants to run around attention
and he's always
h-u-n-g-r-y he knows what that word is
so I can't say it out loud and he
doesn't know what it spouts he doesn't
know what that spouse what what Harry
Potter's character oh what a spouse
he doesn't know it
he'll learn guitar
ten minutes of cat love run away
run away and go get into something that
you can eat all right guys well
um
Merry Christmas and let's send this for
the patreon
Maria Hammond I wanted to shout you out
because you have gifted Olivia and I
with some truly spectacular gifts
um because we are to be wet
very very soon it is true and uh the
it's just like
you've been uh obnoxiously generous like
you've not just made it a more exciting
time to get married but also uh a better
Christmas overall and a great way to
start the new year so thank you for
always sharing your your soul being
vulnerable with me but uh and then
gifting us but you can literally stop I
want you to do it enough you can stop
your love is received I I I love the
hell out of you but you've gone like
what above and beyond this is so many
ways that I almost don't I mean like
I've shown you photos where some of the
stuff is uh in our home but yeah this is
you know if you want to keep going you
can but yeah
you can literally stop right now and
you're covered for like at least a year
you know yeah maybe until we start to be
like hey Maria so I feel a little
neglected over here so thank you my dear
for uh being amazing I hope you're able
to have a great Christmas with your
family and I I also hope that that 2023
ends up being a sharper year for you
than 2022 was I really do love you thank
you
[Music]